[Music]
it's a new month which means a bunch of
brand new games want to take your time
and become your new bay october isn't as
packed as usual this year as new
consoles drop in november
but there is still a ton of new things
to play including three
free-to-play titles if you need to save
your pennies
enough jibber-jabber let's do this
the biggest game of the month is
arguably watchdogs legion
releasing on october 29th the third
installment in the franchise which
continually
improves each iteration the big gimmick
this time around is the ability to
recruit anyone
in the city almost all npcs can become
part of the resistance
i played the preview build last month
and gotta say that mechanic changes
everything
recruiting a badass granny is something
we all need to try in 2020
and by slowly freeing areas of the city
which this time is london by the way
a new high skilled npc becomes available
to your ranks
like a secret agent if you're lucky each
of the characters has their own perks
such as firearms vehicles tech options
and style choices too over the course of
the campaign you'll hack and fight your
way to the album ceo
who runs the city with his private
military and just in case you're
wondering
should you pick this game up on ps4 or
xbox one you will automatically get the
next gen option the ps5 option as soon
as you need it
game we've waited over 20 years for a
sequel lands on october 2nd
crash bandicoot 4 it's about time it's
finally time for a new outing and coco
is here
she's only one of five playable
characters all tasked with
understanding the rips in time speaking
of that
crash 4 allows us to collect vhs tapes
if you don't know what they are please
ask a parent we use these to travel back
in time to before the events of the
first game
expect to have the usual reversed and
mirrored levels which will add to the
replayability of the game
another great thing of note is the
multiplayer both competitive and
cooperative with games like checkpoint
race
and crate combo in which you race to
checkpoints and break crates
hmm you could have figured that one out
yourself october the second on ps4 and
xbox one if this is your jam
[Music]
we're approaching the spooky time of
year so what about a horror game
or two the dark pictures anthology
little hope
okay the title is is less than
imaginative and terribly long
but look past that please little hope is
a survival horror game which plays out
cinematically like a movie one year ago
the first part of the series released
named man of medan
don't worry if you haven't played that
one yet the stories are unique with only
a few general themes carried over
little hope spans multiple eras with
flashbacks to a witch hunt in
1692 and yeah you've guessed it
you're the one there hunting there is a
cooperative mode to play with a friend
too
you know if you're a wimp like me if you
want to play this yourself look out for
it the day before
halloween on october 30th on ps4 pc
and xbox okay let's get another horror
game out of the way please
amnesia rebirth a chillingly scary game
series which has terrified many since
2010
a journey through desolation and despair
and the limits of human resistance
heck no i'm not touching this at all if
you are
october the 20th on ps4 and pc
okay i think we need to lighten the mood
with four guys
the smash hit game of august is back
with a massive update
as soon as october 6th season 2 takes
everything we know
and yeets it up to 10. the season will
be based around the theme of medieval
so expect vikings wizards and dragons
and weapons and items from the middle
ages like drawbridges and battle axes
this season introduces interactable
elements and movable objects we'll be
pushing blocks into place to climb walls
and lowering bridges to create paths too
so if you've fallen off fall guys
i'm sure the new season will bring more
content we've needed it for a while now
i'll see you on the battlefield and note
there is an xbox and switch version
coming soon
but i'm not sure how soon i'll keep you
updated ps4 and pc players
see you on october 6th
[Music]
next we have a new star wars title star
wars squadrons
a space combat game set just after the
events of return of the jedi
we'll take control of galactic empire
and new republic ships
and manage our vessels defense and
attacking options
in a frantic firefight in space the four
classes available
are fighter interceptor bomber and
support there's also a story campaign
based around two customizable pilots
i'm gonna butcher these names but i'll
give them a go rau hi moon from new
republic's vanguard squadron
and case casandora from the empire's
titan squadron just for you people who
like lore in their games
is this game for you october the second
on ps4 pc
and xbox
so let's look at some of those free
games first
bless unleashed is bandai namco's new
mmo
how to quote them it's an online
multiplayer action rpg
the peaceful city of tellerium is
attacked by a sorcerer
somehow we survive and vow revenge and
we're going to take them down
every last one of them all in the name
of justice of course
with five classes to start ranging from
the tank style berserker to the magic
wielding mages
the game asks us to explore the world
uncovering secrets
and levelling characters the combo
system helps bless
unleashed stand out from its peers and
unlike other
mmos there's no health regen here
dodging is a key ability
staggered releases for bless unleashed
releasing on ps4 on october 22nd full pc
release is early 2021
and xbox peeps you already have it right
now and it's free
enjoy hey psvr gamers i found a free
game for you guys coming in october
mortal blitz combat arena as it's vr
you'll be dodging in real time
in real life around objects and shields
popping up to take the shot you need
the movement mechanic is warp based so
you can teleport around the battlefield
this should assist anyone with motion
sickness issues and as this is online
with other people you'll never play the
same game twice
grab this for free on october 8th on
psvr
and now a free-to-play game which
released in september and i
totally missed it my bad have you tried
spellbreak yet
yes it's another battle royale title and
i know some people are becoming quite
fatigued with that
but spellbreak is different and feels
more like an mmo its art style its feel
its abilities
to start with each character has an
intrinsic ability based on an element
that could be
rock it could be ice fire i personally
like the toxic gas as it's just like me
in real life
then on the battlefield we pick up a
second ability again it's elemental
based like lightning or wind
you get the idea and then a third
ability again picked up on the
battlefield which is more tactical than
weaponized there is an invisibility
cloak there's a fast travel option
there's
teleportation and for the ultra
aggressive there's an ability which
shows the location of
other players i honestly believe this
could be huge and right now the player's
skill base
isn't too high which means learning the
basics now is the best time to do it
because in a month or two people will be
getting damn good
i'm jumping back in tonight spell break
is already here so you can download it
right now for free
on ps4 xbox and pc
to end all this let's go back to full
price games and something i really
should talk about
is the new fifa update but if i'm honest
people either buy fifa or they don't
it's an annual sports title with minor
updates
but if you want that fifa 21 releases on
october 9th
the game i'd like to finish on and bring
your attention to is dirt 5.
the dirt series was always a super
realistic simulation game originating in
2007 when it was named
colin mcrae dirt and before that the
series started in 1998.
i feel old the reason i bring this up
now is because the game is ever so
slightly becoming a touch more
arcadey with each update simulation
racers are very difficult for casual
gamers to embrace
and now dirt is trying to attract both
audiences with improved controls
and a story with acting juggernauts troy
baker and nathan drake
i mean nolan north supplying the voices
this is another game which automatically
upgrades to ps5 and xbox series x
nice so there we have it
is anyone still here i'm guessing not
those were the 10 games to look out for
in october
but you don't care because you've
already left rip the dream
i'm adam from playstation grenade hi if
you're still here
i hope your day is going well we should
chat like this more often
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you